global climate change is wreaking havoc
on this planet in the pacific many
islands are projected to disappear like
atlantis in the arctic polar ice caps
are melting
in australia devastating brush fires
have killed three billion animals and in
america we're getting once in a century
storms twice a decade and like with most
things
it's up to the lawyers to save the day
because whether the world acts to
mitigate the effects of climate change
depends a lot on the state of the law in
the world's most developed nations
and when the law has to change who are
you going to call
lawyers
[Music]
brought to you in partnership with bill
gates hey league legals it's time to
think like
well a lawyer because like it or not the
lawyers are going to have a role
in fighting climate change because
climate change is a global problem which
demands global solutions
and often emissions that are made in one
area affect another place in the world
if not the world at large so
to really impact the temperature of the
world nations have to act in concert
over the long term for decades however
the ability of the world to tackle
climate change depends substantially on
how
sovereign nations are constrained by
their own form of government
and especially their laws and not all
countries view climate change the same
way
denmark for instance passed a law that
made climate change actually illegal and
now every year the danish government
will need to find a majority
parliamentary approval of its global and
national climate strategies
the law commits denmark to making all
major policy decisions through a green
lens to
assess their impact on climate and the
country has to share
green technologies with other nations so
that they can reduce emissions eight of
the ten parties in the danish parliament
voted for the law which limits how much
future governments can undermine it but
what's possible in denmark might not be
possible
in the u.s and right now the united
states is not exactly known for passing
bipartisan legislation so
america's strategy may be more well
american because in america we just sue
each other so if you're climate mindful
you probably wonder how
individuals might be able to pressure
the government to act
through lawsuits and naturally many
people have attempted to sue fossil fuel
companies for the emissions that are a
byproduct of
those products and lawsuits in europe
have had some success in this
area particularly last march a uk court
of appeals said that plans to expand
heathrow airport
were unlawful because they failed to
take the paris climate agreement into
account
but in america climate change plaintiffs
have yet to find big success in federal
court
the first major hurdle for american
litigants is whether cases can satisfy
the threshold procedural requirements
for a court to even decide a case
these include concepts like standing
which examines whether litigants are the
right parties to bring a lawsuit
most recent cases brought by american
citizens have been knocked out at these
early stages of litigation for example a
2018 case brought by oregon children
initially satisfied a motion to dismiss
but the ninth circuit court of appeals
reversed the child plaintiffs asserted
that they had a fifth amendment right to
a
climate system capable of sustaining
human life but the ninth circuit said
that the kids lack standing to bring the
claims the court rejected the premise
that courts should decide climate change
issues saying that only the legislative
and executive branches of the government
have that power and this
isn't terribly surprising american
courts aren't supposed
to set policies so many u.s courts have
dismissed lawsuits on the basis that
courts simply can't set a policy where
the executive branch has been given
authority to regulate and that was one
of the issues in the first supreme court
case to decide whether corporations
could be sued for greenhouse gas
emissions
american electric versus connecticut the
lawsuit was filed by eight states new
york city and three land conservation
groups against the tva the tennessee
valley authority as well as several
other power companies the plaintiffs
allege that the defendants were a public
nuisance because their
co2 emissions contributed substantially
to global warming the supreme court held
that only the environmental protection
agency the epa
could set emissions standards and that
the epa's authority prevented plaintiffs
from suing under illegal theory
based on federal common law nuisance law
and
based on the epa's designated authority
it's up to the epa to decide whether and
how to regulate greenhouse gas emissions
from the defendant power plants
states and cities don't have the right
to sue the utility companies in
2021 the supreme court will decide a
major climate change case
but only on the narrow technical issue
about whether the case must be removed
from state court to federal court the
city of baltimore filed the lawsuit in
2018 against oil and gas companies
saying that their products had dangerous
impacts on climate injuring baltimore
citizens
and defendants filed a motion to remove
the case to federal court now the fourth
circuit eventually decided the case
should remain in state court defendants
petitioned the supreme court for review
because the circuit courts differ
on the federal grounds for removal and
whether the state courts needed to
review every ground for removal and
right now your eyes may be glazing over
with boredom since
this seems like a side skirmish in a
much bigger battle and while this
is definitely a technical issue at the
same time the court's ruling will
certainly
impact the speed at which climate change
cases are reviewed but it's also
possible the supreme court may express
doubt about the judiciary's rule in
deciding climate change cases the
supreme court doesn't like to decide
things it doesn't absolutely have to and
this would mean punting on these
substantive issues so that america's
extremely high functioning very
efficient senate
and house of representatives could pass
beautiful legislation i have a feeling
it's going to be beautiful
and even if plaintiffs survive early
motions to dismiss liability
determinations are very complicated to
sort out how much
fault can you attribute to one
particular defendant what happens when
all of the emissions are
co-mingled and how do you divvy out the
damages amongst the entire world and
plaintiffs would have to show that the
defendants created actual harm and
damages to the plaintiffs this involves
a battle of experts and
real questions about remedies and while
european litigants have been successful
in changing actual policy
the difficulty of determining a remedy
has prompted many american courts to
question
whether the judicial branch is really
the right forum for these disputes now
at this point the question you're
probably asking is well
what about international law then well
there's a reason
that the us generally doesn't like to
play nice under international rules but
international law is increasingly
playing a major role on climate disputes
with
good reason for example smaller island
nations are in an especially precarious
position the intergovernmental panel on
climate change reported in 2014 that one
meter of sea level rise would wipe out
15 percent of pacific islands and that
means the destruction of many people's
homes and entire cultures for example
tavalu
an island of approximately 10 000 people
has a high point of only 13 feet above
sea level their citizens claim that the
actions of the world's industrialized
nations are slowly flooding the island
tuvalu is arguing that some nations owe
them compensation and although
industrialized nations make up only 20
of the world's population
they account for 60 of the annual carbon
dioxide emissions
and america is responsible for 25 of all
global greenhouse gas emissions all on
its own
so tuvalu is threatening to sue the us
and australia since both are not
signatories to the kyoto protocol the
climate change treaty that requires
lower greenhouse gas emissions from
industrialized nations now a claim like
that might conceivably be brought in the
united nations international court of
justice
every country that is a member of the un
is a member of the court but not all
countries accept its jurisdiction the
icj
has two kinds of jurisdiction first the
court has jurisdiction over disputes
between states that have accepted the
jurisdiction of the court there are 74
governments that accept the icj's
jurisdiction
but the us is not one of them however if
tuvalu wanted to bring a lawsuit against
a country that was part of the icj
it probably could the icj decides cases
using international conventions and
customs
its decisions however generally don't
apply as precedent and on top of that
the court's decision binds only the
parties to that particular case and
controversy and the icj's second type of
jurisdiction is the ability to give
advisory opinions the un general
assembly or the security council may
request
an opinion from the icj these opinions
would not be binding but they can
influence public policy many pacific
islands are now pushing for an advisory
opinion on climate change through the
icj
but even if they were successful that
would be a non-binding decision
so international lawsuits are not likely
to have a huge effect on u.s policy as
it stands
so the bottom line is that the lawyers
are trying to save the day but those
pesky judges and courts
just keep getting in the way which means
that we're going to have to turn to
and i hate to say it the politicians
we're going to have to adopt
some new laws and not only that but some
of the laws that we've already adopted
are
frankly counterproductive so the
question is what laws should america
pursue
well first we can turn to some global
success stories regarding greenhouse gas
emissions for example norway has
aggressively targeted gasoline and
diesel burning cars
creating incentives for electric
vehicles electric cars now account for
about half of all vehicles in norway
which you would know if you've ever seen
a gm ad featuring will ferrell
no way norway knock knock it's america
and we're gonna punch you in the face
now every major automotive manufacturer
in the world is developing fleets of
plug-in vehicles american lawmakers can
create incentives for electric cars
the european union banned the use of
hydrofluorocarbons which
are greenhouse gases used in air
conditioners and refrigerators the u.s
can and has in the past taken similar
action british columbia adopted a
carbon tax it has caused emissions to
fall and there have been in the past
times when american citizens were
willing to pay so-called sin
taxes taxes on booze and cigarettes in
order to finance
things like sports stadiums canada and
the us agreed in 2016 to curb methane
emissions from oil and gas operations
the trump administration rolled back a
lot of those efforts but it's possible
that the biden administration
could unroll back those efforts if they
wanted to and while there have been
global success stories there have also
been some local state-based
success stories as well here in the
united states for example california has
been leading the way on energy efficient
building standards since the 1970s the
state standards continued to get
stricter as new technologies arrive on
the scene and
if these standards were adopted
throughout the united states it would
impact emissions for heating and cooling
on a nationwide basis states like new
york and california already require
utilities to produce their electricity
from zero carbon sources
that means that solar wind water and
potentially nuclear power are more
enticing if the rest of the nation
followed suit it could mean a huge
reduction in co2 emissions and the new
york times estimates that if the us
adopted these policies
it would quote slash greenhouse gas
emissions united states by roughly 29
below 2005 levels by 2025 and roughly 50
by 2050 and then there are some more
controversial but potentially
even more efficacious policies available
like cap and trade which allows
individuals more choice over how they
reduce emissions now cap and trade as
most people envision it is a different
method than the typical command and
control approach where the government
just simply sets performance standards
or forces consumers to pick electric
vehicles for instance cap and trade
allows the market to determine the price
on carbon and the price drives
investment decisions and spurs market
innovation
is this a tax well cap and trade differs
from tax in that it provides a high
level of certainty about future
emissions
but not about the price of those
emissions which leads to a question
about the constitutionality of a cap and
trade policy
because a policy is only as good as
whether it is
constitutional in the first place to be
implemented so while some have
questioned whether a federal cap and
trade program would be constitutional
because of the limits of the
constitution's commerce clause
some states have had a cap and trade
program for a pretty long time
for example california which has had a
cap and trade program for many years
and has an agreement with quebec through
a cross-linked border market
the regulated actors in the two
jurisdictions were able to trade their
allocated emissions allowances but the
state's program was challenged by the
trump administration which basically
claimed that california couldn't
engage in foreign policy that that was
reserved solely for the federal
government but so far california has
been successful at the federal trial
level and has been allowed to continue
with its particular agreement and then
there's the possibility of truly local
or state-based measures or potentially
even a federal framework to eliminate
zoning restrictions or soften zoning
restrictions to allow for greater
density in city centers
because as it happens individuals who
live in big dense cities tend to produce
far less waste and produce far fewer
greenhouse gas emissions and there are
many reasons for it number one
if you live in a big city that allows
you to walk around or has public transit
then you're probably not going to be
polluting via a car
and you're probably living in a big
building that while on an absolute level
is producing more emissions
when you divide it by the sheer number
of people that are living in it it
actually produces far less on a per
person basis so the cities tend to be on
a per person basis
far more efficient than the suburbs and
the rural areas as well and of course
not everyone wants to move into a big
density and that's perfectly fine too no
one needs to force anyone to do it but
the truth is a lot more people want to
move into these big
more efficient cities but currently
can't because it's either too expensive
or there's not enough housing or both
and a lot of that is spurned by the
actual laws that are currently on the
books things like
zoning that currently limit the amount
of infill development that could
house more people more efficiently all
the people that want to move into those
cities but let me get down for my
soapbox this video was not intended to
be a survey of every possible solution
that's out there
far from it there's a lot more that
lawyers and
normal people can actually do to help
prevent climate change
really the idea was just to spark
inspiration in other professionals who
you might not assume have a role to play
but if even the lawyers can get involved
i guarantee other people can as well and
this video was created in partnership
with bill gates and inspired by his new
book
how to avoid a climate disaster you can
find out more about how we can all work
together to avoid a climate disaster
using the link below